[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOB SEDDIGH: So my
name is Bob Seddigh.
I'm a VP of cloud
engineering for Atos.
And I'm currently
based in London.
For those of you close enough
to the front of the stage
to be able to count the
rings under my eyes,
I think you can correlate
that to the number
of hours' difference between
London and San Francisco.
So in today's
session, we are going
to look at the role of
hybrid clouds in acceleration
transformation to cloud.
Is a really big topic.
It is quite complex.
There's a lot of technologies
involved so we can really
only scratch the surface.
But before we start
that, I'd like
to just make a quick
introduction about what Atos
is, who we are, and what we do.
So Atos are a global digital
services leader operating
in 73 different countries.
We've got in excess
of 120,000 people
with an annual revenue of
circa 12 billion euros.
We provide quite a wide
variety of IT services,
spanning from digital
transformation,
managed services,
application development,
application transformation,
security, big data.
You name it, we do it.
Well established organization.
April last year we announced
a global enhanced alliance
partnership with Google focusing
on hybrid cloud, machine
learning, AI, digital
workplace, and security.
And I'm very proud
that this year we've
been recognized as the Google
Cloud global breakthrough
partner.
So Atos and Google are driving
six distinct innovation tracks
focusing on increasing
application agility,
enabling SAP on cloud,
IoT, enhanced real time
collaboration,
artificial intelligence,
and secure hybrid clouds.
So the agenda for today.
In today's session,
we're going to start
by putting a little
bit of business context
around what it is that
enterprises are striving to do.
We're going to try to drill
down from that position
into what sort of
transformations
need to take place.
We're also going to look at
some of the typical challenges
enterprise has
experienced and how
working with a trusted
partner can alleviate
some of those burdens.
And we'll move into the role
of holistic hybrid clouds
in helping to accelerate.
And hopefully, I'm going
to be able to get the time
to also spend a few minutes to
tell you about a product launch
that we did this Tuesday at
Google Next for our newest
hybrid cloud offering.
And we'll close this
session with a bit of Q&A.
And if there isn't
sufficient time,
I'm more than happy to take
questions after the session.
And obviously we'll be at
the stall the entire day.
So regardless of the sector
an enterprise organization
is operating within, there are
quite a lot of common themes
that we all strive
to achieve to,
especially in the context
of a global digital market.
We see these things
across pretty much all
of our customers and
actually we recognize
those exact same
things internally
within our own organization.
And they're
relatively simplistic.
We all strive for
agility, the ability
to be the disruptor
rather than the disrupted.
We strive to have
data driven businesses
where the decision making
is based on analytics
and real time data.
We want to increase our revenue
base through the introduction
of differentiated offerings.
And we want to do that in a way
where we are cost controlling
and making sure the solutions
we're pulling together
are cost optimal
and competitive.
So to achieve these aims,
there is quite a lot of change
that's required.
Business processes
need to change in order
to provide agility.
Security processes
need to change in order
to provide agility.
And equally your application
development methodologies
themselves need to be changing
to give you that agility.
Looking at a data driven
decision making scenario,
again, your
application space needs
to be able to support that.
There needs to be a
consolidation of your data
in order to be able
to effectively apply
machine learning and
analytics to your data.
And equally from a revenue
and cost perspective,
well, in order to
actually find what's
a differentiator in the
market, you need real data.
And you need the real
analytics against that data
to understand what the
demand in the market is.
Automation plays
absolutely huge part
in ensuring that we got
a cost effective solution
and we are able to control
the cost and be competitive.
And equally, cloud
native solutions
enable you to really--
it's the utility model.
It's utilizing resources
at the point you need them,
being able to scale up and
down in line with agility
of your business.
So I want to drill down another
level further down from this
and look at really what are the
transformational spaces that we
need to look into.
So from a business
process perspective,
this is the absolute
bare minimum.
We need to enable the business
to be able to make decisions
based on data and analytics.
IT operations.
Majority of our organizations we
work with are still ITIL based.
They use IT service
management tooling
in order to manage the
environments and processes.
And to achieve the actual
agility that we require,
we need to start moving
more and more and more
towards DevSecops.
You're going to hear me
repeat the word DevSecOps over
and over in this.
And hopefully it's nothing
new to anyone here.
But it's actually really
complex and really hard
space to get into, especially
when your starting point
is traditional IT operations.
Security.
Again, embedding security in the
application development space
as opposed to it being a
wrapper after the fact.
And the bigger
challenge at the moment
is we're in the era of
multi-cloud, hybrid cloud,
on-prem solutions.
And coming up with
processes and technologies
and tools actually are able
to effectively span all three
of those spaces to give
you a consolidated view
of your security
is a tough task,
similar with your
processes around security.
Not unlike the rest
of IT services,
I think automation is absolutely
key within the security space.
So we need to look at
the ways of automating
security processes, security
testing, security governance,
within our, essentially, things
like our CI/CD pipelines,
policy driven architectures
whereby we can articulate
policies-- that's
security policies
and other business policies-- in
a way where the technology can
enforce them.
And anyone who is working
in regulated industries
or with governmental
bodies will be
aware of the amount
of work that needs
to be done with the
legislative bodies,
with the government bodies,
in essentially trying
to bring him up to speed with
the cloud native technologies.
They have to go on the
same transformation,
and understanding, and
learning that we all do.
And we have to bring
them along with us.
So this is not a short term fix.
And it's going to
take some time.
And later on we'll
look at some ways
that we can try to help
accelerate at least parts
of this process so that the
whole thing is not [INAUDIBLE]..
Application development.
Back to DevSecOps, putting the
appropriate practices in place
so we are able to
effectively get agility out
of our application
development space,
putting the right quality
assurance and testing
capabilities, including the
security we touched upon within
our CI/CD pipelines, adoption
of all these new technologies--
so Kubernetes cloud
functions, X as a service--
by X as a service I'm talking
about things like PaaS,
SaaS, database as a
service, AML as a service,
big data as a service.
So all of those
types of technologies
need to be adopted.
Why do they need to be adopted?
Because they form the building
blocks of your applications.
Your applications
developers do not
have to recreate those
things from scratch.
They're ready to be consumed.
And it's critical that we
start moving our applications
towards using those ready made
services and building blocks
that are managed by
managed service providers
so your business can
concentrate on developing
applications for
a line of business
as opposed to caring
about under the hood IT.
We've got to be realistic.
At this point in time,
the vast majority
of the applications that
are in the enterprise space
are still not cloud native.
And at a rough guess, I would
say 95% of the applications
are not cloud native.
And that's probably
somewhat generous.
So we still got to
be aware that we've
got a significant
portion of work
to do in order to
transform, replace, refactor
those applications to get
them to a cloud native space.
Data consolidation.
So separation of the code
from data is absolutely key.
And especially when we
start looking at technology
such as Kubernetes where,
essentially, the code
base is running in a pod,
that pod can be killed.
And it can be recreated
as many times as you like.
It can be scaled up.
It can be scaled down.
The data mustn't be
affected from that.
So separating code
from data is absolutely
crucial at this stage.
And it's a real difficult task
to do with legacy applications.
But we also have to
look at centralization
and normalization of
that data in order
to then effectively
apply analytics.
If anyone's worked with the
AI/ML type of technologies,
machine learning, it's
somewhat of an area
where there is a lot of
experimentation required.
You're not always sure about the
viability of a particular idea
being modelable in an effective
way through machine learning.
So experimentation is required.
And we need to
build capabilities
where we can do
proof of concepts
but very rapidly take a
proof of proof of concept
that we've shown to be working
into a production level
application.
And this is probably
worthwhile mentioning
from an AI/ML perspective
and analytics as a whole.
It's a bi-directional
relationship
in terms of the
way that it drives
the business or the
business drives it.
So your practices
from AI/ML perspective
have got to be able to
respond to business demand
and be able to model
things and predict things
as the business requires.
But equally we've got to
be open to the challenges
that information
and analytics led
sources can lead to us
changing our business models.
Automation, again, is
an absolute key theme
throughout this presentation in
being able to automate as much
of the processes
because your agility is
highly dependent on it.
And we're getting into
a space at the moment
where more and more things are
getting easier to automate.
And we got to ensure things
like quality assurance, testing,
and the security side are
really effectively addressed
through the automation piece.
And CI/CD is one answer.
CI/CD is a methodology.
CI/CD enables you to
encode your business rules
and practices, your security
capabilities, testing.
From our own
internal perspective,
for example when we're
developing our cloud platforms,
our CI/CD pipelines
actually include whole set
of security testing around
scanning the code for quality,
for inadvertent insertion
of vulnerabilities,
for upstream reliance
on upstream libraries
that may have vulnerabilities
included within them,
and the QA side
of things equally.
So we want to get to a point
where an application developer
checking code in
automatically triggers
a whole set of pipelines that
would automatically give you
to a point where
you have confidence
that code is sufficiently
tested to directly deploy
into production.
That's where you get
your agility from.
And that's got to cover
security and the technology
and everything
else to do with it.
It's got to be policy driven.
Again, going back to
the point of being
able to encode business rules,
policies, legislative rules,
policies, all of those things
in a way where they can
programmatically be tested as
part of your ability to deploy
and also to build
your solutions.
And we've got to adopt all
the cloud native technology.
So those who are familiar
with the Kubernetes space
probably understand the
analogy of cattle versus pet.
When we look at the current
existing set of applications
we're dealing with,
enterprise applications
are typically very stateful.
We really care about the
state of our virtual machines
and our servers.
If they die, they take
things down with them
that affects our business.
In cloud native world, we are in
a complete different scenario.
We don't patch a server.
We create a new pod.
We start directing some of
the traffic towards that pod.
If it's successful
and it's not failing,
we start diverting all of
the traffic to the new pod
and we get rid of the old one.
Mentalitywise, it's
a mindset shift.
Your application development
and QA processes is a shift
and actually gaining agility.
But it has a reliance or your
applications being architected
in a way where they're able to
support that kind of mechanism.
And your operational
practices has
got to be aligned to being
able to do that kind of testing
to be able to understand
the effect of introducing
a new version of a service and
directing a portion of doing
canary testing for example.
So it's a lot of work
to be done there.
And I mentioned this
before around the X
as a service, whatever it is
as a service, adoption of those
in order to accelerate the
actual application development
process.
So the cloud challenge.
We are transforming
far more than IT.
And we are barely
skirting around the edges
of the non-IT elements in
this particular presentation,
but there are cultural
shifts that need to happen.
There are business
processes that
need to happen, the
security processes,
the legislative stuff that
we've got to deal with.
When we look at our typical
customer scenarios of what they
go through when they start
looking at transformation
and moving to public cloud,
quite often the starting point
is looking at their regulatory
and compliance needs.
And that typically forms
some sort of a concept
or architecture around what
they need to do for security,
and their networking, and
usually is fairly traditional
based rather than
cloud native approaches
that are adopted because,
at that stage, all of us
are in the same boat.
We haven't quite learned
what we need to be doing.
Then we start looking at the
selective applications being
transformed or adopting
ready-made cloud native
applications in order
to satisfy our needs.
So we then end up
in a position where
we've got selective applications
are on public cloud.
The rest of our
environment is still
in a non-cloud native
mode and not on-prem.
And it is usually at this
stage that most businesses
that we have been
working with have
a realization that the pace
of public cloud adoption
is far, far slower
than they would like.
And in order to accelerate
that, most organizations
go down the path of
looking to lift and shift.
There's a few problems.
So we've got our existing
application space, the legacy
applications or traditional
application space which
is not cloud native, traditional
operations around it,
traditional security around it.
You're talking about change
control boards, cabs,
people approving changes
being applied into production.
And now we've got a
set of applications
which are completely
different in the way they're
being managed and they're
cloud native and living
in public cloud.
So one or two things can happen.
You either enforce your
existing IT processes
on top of your
cloud native stuff
that have been deployed on
public cloud, in which case
you are reducing the agility
of the entire solution,
or you end up in a
mixed mode of operations
where the cloud
native stuff is dealt
with in a different
way to your on-prem
or traditional applications.
And if it's not planned
upfront really well,
you end up with an inconsistent
application of controls.
So governance, IT governance,
technical governance,
security governance-- it
can end up in a position
where you have a complete
mismatch and inability
to consciously say that
you've applied your governance
practices equally
across the board.
So when we start looking
at a holistic hybrid cloud,
and I intentionally keep
putting the word holistic here
because it's much more than
just the cloud platforms
themselves-- when
we start looking
at a holistic hybrid cloud
ecosystem, what does it do?
It extends and brings the
cloud to your premises.
Simplistic.
Allows you to do a coexistent
model and a bimodal mode
of operations.
So we have to delve
into that much more.
But there are certain
characteristics
that these clouds need to
have in order to enable that.
But they also enable us,
at least in the short term,
to protect our
existing investments.
And we have a hell
of a lot of customers
who are going through this
journey to public cloud.
And the reality of the situation
is, and this is not uncommon.
We talk to them and they've
got a 10-year lease on a data
center that cannot
be changed overnight.
They've got that existing
investment and finding a way
where we are protecting
that existing investment is
critical.
And I think hybrid clouds
is one way to address
that in the short term.
So what are the characteristics
of a hybrid cloud in order
to enable those things?
These are
[? opinionated. ?] Need
to be open standards
and native API based.
By that I mean, for example,
open source, standard APIs
that are not proprietary.
And that is to enable
essentially integration
with orchestration tools
with CMP tools that
are available out there
without getting locked in.
Need true hybrid
capability in order
such that if you start
developing your applications
on the private cloud
element of a hybrid,
you don't have to spend the same
R&D or application development
time to then transform
and run in public.
You want to do the
development work once.
You do it once.
In a true hybrid
cloud environment,
you should be able to have
the full portability in order
to move them to
public cloud when
the rest of the processes
and things that you
need to change within the
organization are ready for it.
CI/CD and policy driven
architecture we've
talked about already.
Absolutely crucial that
your hybrid cloud solutions
are able to support
these methodologies.
And again, it goes
back to the point
of being able to present out
standardized non-proprietary
open APIs.
That means that
whatever work you
do in developing your CI/CD
pipelines, again, is reusable
regardless of what
cloud you run it on.
And this is another key point.
So we still have got our
existing traditional IT service
processes.
They're not going to
go away overnight.
And we need to maintain those
services and processes in order
to ensure our governance
is still there.
So we still need a way of
bridging the old and the new.
So a true hybrid
cloud solution needs
to give you the capability
whereby you're integrating
your actual processes, your
ITSM toolsets with that platform
but in a way where it's
not affecting agility
and the ability to use
CI/CD capabilities.
It's a hard thing
to do, but I think
that is an absolute
crucial requirement
for a true hybrid
cloud solution.
Many of you know
adoption of public cloud.
Again, it's a topic that is
driven sometimes by emotion.
To be truly successful
in adopting cloud,
your developers need to love
working in that environment.
They need to see advantage.
They need to see a
different way of working.
They'll have to like it.
If they don't like it, they
will go and do something else.
That's the reality.
We've seen adoption of public
cloud come about in pockets
of line of business
applications within our clients
purely because the developers
like the ecosystem that they
have on public cloud.
So to make hybrid
cloud successful,
we need to make sure we are
providing the developers
with the same set
of capabilities,
the same set of tools that
they actually want to use,
and helps them to develop
their applications on-prem.
So why is it
different this time?
There's been so many iterations
of technologies changing,
new things coming along.
We had virtualization
10 years back
coming along and
with the promises
that it would
completely transform
the way we do business.
I do think we're at the
unique point at the moment.
We've got a real convergence of
the infrastructure, application
and security, technologies,
methodologies,
all of those things
coming together
so DevSecOps, CI/CD
capabilities, automated QA,
cloud native stateless
applications, AI/ML, analytics.
All of these things have come
to converge at the same time
to enable us to do a far more
successful transformation
than we were able to do before.
And the hybrid cloud
environment has
got to enable you
to take advantage
of all of those
technologies and has
to actually drive the usage
of those technologies.
So we've only barely
touched on these things.
But there's a hell of a
lot of new technologies.
There's a hell of a lot of new
processes, new ways of thinking
about things.
There's a lot of
learning to be done
by the entirety of
our organizations.
And it's challenging.
It's really crucial,
I think, for everyone
to think about working
with trusted partners that
can help them work through
some of these challenges,
bring the right
skills to the table,
and help organizations adapt
their existing application
development practices
to be DevSecOps based,
teach you about the technologies
where it's necessary,
and adopt all of these things.
I think it's crucial
to try to avoid
all of the typical pitfalls by
getting help from your trusted
partners.
In our case, when we have a
partnership between someone
that is helping you transform
your business and the cloud
provider, it's a
three way partnership,
which brings a lot more value.
So I'm going to quickly
summarize the stuff
that we talked about today.
Transformation is
at every level.
It's not just in the
technology space.
It is in the people space.
It is in the culture
of the organization.
It is the entirety of
your business processes,
your security processes,
your application development
processes.
So it is at every single level.
But this is the price
of getting agility.
If you want your businesses
to be agile, and be
able to compete, and come
up with those differentiated
offerings, this is the
sort of transformation
that needs to be taking place.
We need to get to
a place where we're
able to encode business
processes, our governance,
our security all into automated
ways of applying those,
so CI/CD through automated
policy enforcement.
We have to ensure that whatever
solutions we put forward
are capable of
supporting these things.
Hybrid clouds can significantly
accelerate movement
to cloud, public cloud, cloud
overall, adoption of cloud.
Why?
Because they allow you to
parallelize your activity.
So if you looked at
that typical scenario
that I was talking through
earlier where we were talking
to the legislators
or governing bodies,
see what we're
allowed to do, looking
at changing our
security practices,
looking at changing
our network practices.
Once we've done that, we start
doing pockets of applications.
If you have a hybrid
cloud environment
to do your development
work on, and it's
got all of the same capabilities
or the vast majority
of the core capabilities that
you need for your developers
to do cloud native
application development
but on-prem within the
confines of your own security
space, your existing
network space, et cetera,
you're [? parallelizing ?]
that set of activities.
So by nature, you're
going to shorten
the time scales required to
do the overall transformation.
And it's leading by example.
When it comes to bringing the
legislators or auditing bodies
alongside with you, you
have real life examples
running on-prem that are
compliant to the existing
security requirements but also
demonstrate what can be done.
We talked about
the hybrid clouds
needing to provide the right
ecosystem that developers
want to adopt.
They've got to be
developer centric.
If we don't hit that
piece, like I said,
your developers
will go elsewhere,
do it some other way.
And we end up with that
mixed governance model
and the inability to apply
the right level of governance
controls where all
of us, including me,
on a learning journey
continuously, some
of these technologies
are bleeding edge.
They're developing.
Every day something new happens,
something new functionality
comes out.
So it's working with
your trusted partners
in order to accelerate and
de-risk that transformation.
So I'm really proud and excited
to present the Atos OpenHybrid
Cloud platform, which was
launched on Tuesday morning
at this event.
I'm going to try to keep the
marketing elements of this
to a bare minimum.
But in short, OHC is a
managed hybrid cloud platform
and that at a base
level provides both IaaS
and Kubernetes in
the same box, which
means you have dynamic
scaling between the two.
It provides SaaS and
PaaS services that
are mirroring what is on GCP--
database as a service, big
data as a service, AI/ML.
And it's got hybrid
capabilities.
So I'm sure you've seen the
keynote speeches on Anthos.
Anthos is embedded
within this product.
And you are able
to use this product
in both a true private mode--
so if you're not quite ready
to open up your network
and have a true
hybrid capability,
you can start off
with it being private
and dynamically
change configuration
to move it into hybrid mode.
OHC is cost optimized.
It is entirely based on
open source technologies.
And we have been working
with our partners
Google to ensure the
set of technologies
that we built on this
platform are API compatible.
And again, going
back to the point
of being able to develop your
applications once and deploy
them into any cloud,
that's the work
that we've been doing
for the past four months
in order to ensure
that interoperability.
From a DevOps
perspective, all the APIs
are available for consumption.
The native APIs-- there
are no proprietary APIs.
Everything that is on the
platform is open standards.
And all the third party tools
for orchestration, CMPs, et
cetera, all integrate
with it out of the box.
It is really
intended as a gateway
to accelerate move
to public cloud.
And it is extremely
developer centric.
So like I said, all of
the APIs are fully exposed
and they are the native APIs.
We are the first Google
partner to implement an ethos
on top of OpenStack.
There's a lot of
advantages on that front,
including the cost
side of things.
But it does allow us to
offer a platform which
is a combination of the IaaS
and the CaaS side of things.
But more crucially,
the ecosystem
that you see on the screen, it
isn't just the hosting elements
of a cloud platform.
It is all the data
services, the key data
services that any application
developer developing
microservices would want to use.
And above and beyond that,
your capabilities are on AI/ML.
There's variants of this in
terms of the hardware models
where we've got
very [? high end ?]
GPU acceleration.
So again, you can do even
the Kubeflow and AI/ML
aspects of it on this platform.
The solution itself incorporates
the concept of policy engine.
Policy engine, and let
me be clear about this,
because there's a lot of
different uses of the word
policy engine.
Many people think of it in terms
of identity access management.
That's not what
I'm talking about.
I'm talking about policies
that represent genuine business
level policies.
So take an example.
An application has
got a requirement
to be PCI DSS compliance.
So that application
can be tagged
to be PCI DSS that's compliant.
Your pipelines and
your policy engine
must prevent that
application being
deployed on top of a platform
which is not PCI DSS compliant.
And when it gets
down to the level
of the actual
technical components
and the way the
services are delivered
and the characteristics
of that platform,
that's where the policy
enforcement comes in and is
able to discern whether this
platform is suitable to deploy
such an application on top of.
It could be more
simplistic than that.
Geofencing.
So we know many countries
around the world
have got policies
about certain data
not leaving their perimeters.
We're able to, for example,
apply a geofencing policy
that says the application
can be deployed
in this particular instance
of the private cloud
or in that region of a
public cloud, but not others.
So we're talking about the
high level business level
policies which then
our solution translates
into a much lower level granular
technical implementation
of those policies.
So there's a couple of more
elements I want to touch on.
So we talked earlier
on about hybrid cloud
integrating with existing ITIL
processes, ITSM tool sets.
So we have created a
level of abstraction
specifically for that purpose.
So we have message
buses, which are actually
based on Google
Pub/Sub, where we
are able to publish
all of the messages
from an event alerting
and CMTB perspective.
So you create a new instance
of a virtual machine,
or you create a new
Kubernetes cluster,
or you spin up a new
application on Kubernetes.
Events will be
published so they can be
consumed by existing tool sets.
You can still apply your
auditing and compliance
using your existing tool sets.
The solution itself
has not got a reliance
to manage services around
the solution or DevOps mode
and don't have a reliance
on those ITSM tools.
But it does allow
that bimodal operation
and marrying up the existing
ITIL processes with the DevOps
side of things.
So talking about that
message bus and the Pub/Sub,
we have an implementation
that pops up
within this platform itself.
We worked with Google to
actually create a solution
where whereby we've got 100% API
compatible version of Pub/Sub
running [? free ?] locally.
And in hybrid mode, it
creates a connection to GCP
and gives you a single
message bus across GCP
and your private cloud.
It's a really powerful
concept because it
does mean that events, all
of those types of things,
again can be correlated
and collected
in a multi-cloud or hybrid-cloud
scenario-- centralized, viewed,
analyzed.
All of those things
become possible
when you've got ability to span
with one set of technologies
message buses across
one or more clouds.
Manage databases.
Manage the big data services.
Again, these are accelerators.
And because they're API
compatible with the Google
services, it's the same concept.
You write the application
once and you're
able to deploy and consume it
in multiple clouds, private,
or on premise, or on public.
We've got demos of our
platform in the stall.
And I would really welcome
you to come and join us.
So these are live demos.
They're not prerecorded.
We've got a number
of different ones.
We've got an overview
where we just show you
around what the
product looks like
and what the APIs they
offer is and the user
interface within it.
We demonstrate a
hybrid application
being deployed onto
the private cloud,
the same hybrid application
being deployed to public cloud,
and then we split the
application into multiple parts
so the front end web
services for example
run on GCP using ASD service
mesh communicating back
to database services
running on-prem.
So your data stayed on-prem.
Your web service is scalable.
Burst out if you
like into public.
So it's quite powerful stuff.
And we have got
a demo of Anthos.
So we can actually go
into Google console.
We see the private
cloud as appearing
as a region within
the GCP console
and go into the marketplace.
You can select an
application for marketplace
and deploy it directly
onto the private cloud.
It's quite a
powerful thing to be
able to use the marketplace,
all of the work that
goes into creating these
templated applications
and being able to reuse
those regardless of the fact
that you are running on-prem.
[MUSIC PLAYING]